LUKE STONE: Welcome
to The 5th Nine, yeah!
It's pretty awesome to have
a lounge space here, a lounge
space for SRE and DevOps-type
people at The 5th Nine.
It's pretty cool.
So my name's Luke Stone,
and I work at Google
on customer reliability
engineering, which is--
it's a part of SRE--
thank you.
It's a part of SRE
that is focused
on our customers' applications.
And here I have all the
people from Home Depot, who
graced us at Next this year.
And we've been working
with Home Depot
to get their website,
HomeDepot.com,
which is a big e-commerce
website, to get
it running on Google Cloud.
And I wanted to
give them a chance
to tell their story about
what their experience is
of building stuff
on Google Cloud
and how they do
metrics, how they
do multiple zonal resiliency
and stuff, and their experience
with CRE and
building an SRE team.
So I'm going to hand
it over to William,
who is the director
of SRE for Home Depot
and is responsible for keeping
Home Depot Online online.
William?
WILLIAM: Well, and the only
thing I'm going to say here
is that Luke and I just
did a previous session.
So I don't know if anybody
was in that session,
and I promised a few
people that we would
answer more detailed questions.
So I wasn't the really
deep technology guy
to answer those questions.
But we got Jay,
Cuong, and Kumar,
who are SREs at Home Depot.
And if you guys
have some questions,
they're going to talk
about a few things
that you may find of interest.
And if you guys have any
questions, feel free to ask,
all right?
Without further
ado, who's first?
[INAUDIBLE]
LUKE STONE: OK,
here's our agenda.
Our agenda, real
quick, is Cuong is
going to talk about
VALET, which is basically
Home Depot's version of
SLOs, SLAs, you know?
And Kumar's going to talk
about zonal resiliency
and their interconnection with
their on-premise environment.
And Jay's going to
talk about CRE/SRE.
Take it away.
CUONG: Hello, everybody.
My name is Cuong.
I've been working with the
Google Cloud Platform project
at Home Depot for
the past two years.
We are not only leveraging
the Google Cloud Platform
and putting microservices
on the Cloud,
but actually we have been
transforming our web engineer
into an SRE.
Well, the best way to learn
is from the best, Google SRE.
So we have adopted many of
the principle and concept
from Google SRE.
One of them is the SLO.
We require often
microservices before going
live to have a well-defined SLO.
And the responsibility
is between the SRE
and the development team, and
that could mean reaching out
to other stakeholder.
LUKE STONE: So how many
microservices do you have?
CUONG: We probably
have about 70, yes.
LUKE STONE: So you
have to kind of keep
the SLO somewhat
standardized across all
of these microservices.
CUONG: Yes, we do.
We have five key
metrics to our SLO.
We call it VALET,
which is Volume,
Availability,
Latency, and Error.
And then the last
one is tickets.
And most of these, we get
it from our logging system.
And we're using SLOs for
tracking and monitoring.
Also, every week we're
going through all of the SLO
or incident to see if any of the
service is breaching the SLO.
LUKE STONE: So what happens
if a service goes out of SLO?
CUONG: We're going to have
an SRE and a development team
to dig down and find
out what's the problem
and resolve the issue.
And many of the
new microservice,
before it's going
live, we require
it going through a slew
of tests, of load tests,
and destructive tests.
And basically, what
it does is helping
the SRE and the development
team to understand the service
better.
And based on that, either
they adjust the SLO
before it's going live, or
making changes on the service,
to make sure that it's
below the SLO requirement.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, so at
Google, the tradition
is if you miss your SLO, then--
if you go out of SLO in a
month, then you basically
stop pushing new features.
And you shift your work
over towards reliability.
Everybody has a backlog
of reliability stuff
that they can chew into.
Do you guys do
anything like that?
CUONG: Yeah, like I
say, we are transforming
our culture and SRE.
So yeah, we start
enforcing some of those.
Again, but I mean,
that is the culture
that we are moving forward here.
LUKE STONE: And
so do you require
people to create VALET
metrics before they
launch their service?
CUONG: Yes, like I said,
before any microservice,
before it's launched
live, we require
it to have a well-defined SLO.
And then, like I
said, before it's
going live, we go through a
load test and destructive test
and make sure it met the SLO.
Or potentially, that's
just when the time where
they adjust the SLO to make sure
that it's met the requirement.
LUKE STONE: Who's the decider on
what's acceptable for the SLOs?
CUONG: Well, we
have a stakeholder
mostly on our development team.
And that's why I say, SRE
and the development team
work together to agree
on a certain SLO.
LUKE STONE: Nice.
So do you roll
these SLOs all up,
because there's also volume
in there, which isn't really
an SLO thing.
But do you roll them all up
to make a composite score?
CUONG: Currently, we don't.
We look at them as a separate.
So any of those breaking,
then that is breaking SLO.
So right now, we don't have
a one composite number.
LUKE STONE: So in Google SRE,
we have an idea on tickets.
I guess we have more
of a rule of thumb
that you shouldn't get paged
more than twice in a shift.
Is that somewhat what you
use these tickets for?
CUONG: Yeah, right
now, the default we
have, one or two ticket
on most of the SLO.
But I don't think
we are strictly
applying that right now.
But it's something we
probably-- like I say,
it's a culture
that we're probably
going to start
enforcing more as we go.
LUKE STONE: Nice.
And so how do you--
when you have a service
that has latency
because it depends on
another service behind it,
how do you figure out what's
an appropriate latency,
or how do you
measure that latency?
CUONG: Yeah, I think
all the dependency--
so the latency is dependent
on, also, aggregate
with all the dependencies.
So if your microservice
latency is 100,
and then if it's
beyond, above, that,
and that including all the
dependencies-- so we don't--
we just take the aggregate
as a whole, yeah.
LUKE STONE: It's just baked in.
It's just baked in
the whole thing.
JAY: Some of it's handled
by circuit breaker patterns,
and even where
we've had to adjust
SLOs for lower-level
dependencies
because we found that,
hey, you know what?
When we've got a customer
facing API or a service
that has a dependency,
and it's got
to call this service--
so we can't achieve
our availability
for this service
if your SLOs are this loose.
So we've had to tighten some
of those up to make sure
that we could still hit
our overall availability,
especially for
customer-facing components.
LUKE STONE: So I
have a question.
This is probably
somewhat sensitive.
But do you have
any services that
are chronically out of SLO?
CUONG: Actually,
we used to have it,
and then we actually
changed the SLO.
LUKE STONE: That's a
good technique sometimes.
Just make the SLO
reflect reality.
Get back into SLO, and
then start incrementally
improving it.
CUONG: But we did talk back
to the other stakeholder,
and they all agreed.
Like I say, sometimes
the dependency--
it's taken much longer
than we anticipate,
and that's why
we're changing it.
And I think PIP is
one of the products
that we are about to
roll out in a few weeks.
And I think-- before
it's launching,
and it's constantly
go beyond our SLO.
So that's why the SRE team and
development team constantly
try to make the improvements
before it actually goes live.
So before it goes live, we
did a lab test and load test
to make sure that
the SLO is met.
LUKE STONE: Nice.
I think it's pretty impressive
to see their whole system,
because they basically have a
dashboard that they can plug
in all of these
SLO metrics into,
that then their business
stakeholders can just
use this dashboard.
And they don't have to
do what some people have
to do at Google, which is
then go look at the SLO
and try to figure out what it
means, and how it's defined,
and dig, and dig,
and dig, and dig.
It's all really very
clear at Home Depot.
It's pretty cool.
CUONG: I forgot-- so these
are like some of the items
that typically the SRE
and development team have
to go through and come up with.
So typically, we
have a stakeholder.
And then the due
date, typically right
before the launch date-- so
we have to have all these
defined before the
microservice can launch.
So let me just go here.
LUKE STONE: And the
microservices are pretty--
they're pretty similar, right?
They're all web-based,
REST kind of API services.
CUONG: Right, yes,
right-- so here
is one of the sample
microservice that I have here.
So every week that we are
going through the service,
and make sure that
all have met the SRO.
And in this particular
service, if you look at that,
that is sort of like a volume.
When we start out
with the service,
we assume that there should
only be around 450 requests.
But obviously, that is way off.
But that actually
is a good thing,
because actually we can handle
much more than we anticipated.
JAY: So this is
actually an application
that we built to help
us track our SLOs.
So we're using Stackdriver
for most of our monitoring,
but it's not great to use for
tracking your SLOs over time.
So we built the system,
and it takes inputs
from a variety of--
some, ultimately, from
our logs in BigQuery.
We extract data out
of those, and then
push it into-- gather
your aggregated metric
and push it into
this application.
But that also allows us
to expand this beyond just
our Google application.
So the inputs can be
generated from wherever.
So we can even use this
for our critical systems
that are in our on-premise
environment as well.
LUKE STONE: Cool.
Is that basically--
any last thoughts?
CUONG: No, basically,
like I said,
we are trying to
change the culture.
We're not just leveraging
the Google Cloud platform.
We are changing the whole
engineer to become more SRE.
And some of these
are new for us,
so we're continuously going
to keep improving and just--
LUKE STONE: Yeah, it's cool
that you're using data-driven
approach, and it's not just--
you're not winging it.
You have some real, good hard
numbers behind these decisions.
All right, thanks, Cuong.
So, Kumar, you want to tell us--
what's on the next slide?
You were going to
tell us a little bit
about HomeDepot.com global
architecture, right?
KUMAR: Yeah, so I'm Kumar.
I'm the principal
engineer at Home Depot,
and I work closely
with the SRE team.
So this is the high-level,
10,000-foot architecture
for application hosted on GCP.
So there are other components,
but for the sake of simplicity,
we have omitted it.
And this is like a basic stack
of what an application deployed
on the Google Cloud looks like.
So if you look at this
on the extreme left,
there is an on-prem service,
which kind of tells you
that we are in a hybrid model.
There are services which
are hosted on Home Depot
on-prem, which talk to
Google Cloud applications
through the public internet.
And on the right-hand
side, you see the browser,
which is the customer
traffic, which is, again,
obviously coming through the
internet into the Google origin
URL.
So what we have is--
if you guys attended the last
session from Luke and William,
so this is actually
a double-click
on that whole
episode or session.
And [INAUDIBLE] spoke about
an HTTP load balancer.
So we use HTTP load balancers.
So all our requests go to
a central global HTTP LB.
And they get load balanced
across multiple zones
in multiple regions.
So we run on two different
regions-- eastern/central
and two zones in each region.
And so one thing which you
can see from this diagram
or picture is that you
don't see any cross arrows.
You don't see any arrows
which is going from East 1B
to East 1C or from
East 1 to Central.
So basically, that's our pattern
for zone isolation, where
we restrict traffic to a
particular specific zone
for two purposes.
One is it reduces latency
and improves performance,
because your traffic
is within the zone.
And it also reduces
cost, because you're not
paying egress cost for going
to a different zone or region.
More importantly, it helps us
route traffic for failures.
So if a specific service
is not functioning
or if it's down on a zone, then
the LB thinks that it's down.
The health check on that
LB for that service fails,
and the service is routed
to a different zone.
Or if there is a
region failure, it
routes to a different region.
So the only cross-zone
or cross-region traffic,
as you can see from the
picture, is the database.
So we use Cassandra
for SR data store.
And that data has to be
replicated across different--
those regions with all the
apps have the same state they
are talking to, right?
But once the LB
determines which zone
is going to [INAUDIBLE]
the traffic based
on the geolocation,
it stays in that zone
unless there is a
failure, in which it
goes to a different zone.
So that's the
basic architecture.
So we use NGINX web
tier, so that's our--
all our records go through a
centralized web tier or web
layer.
And we have microservices
for each service.
So the requests go from NGINX to
the microservice Tomcat layer,
and from there to the DB.
There are other
components, but this
is the basic
architecture which we
have for all our applications.
So most of the things
that I touched on here--
OK, yeah, so the health
check is then available,
which will route to a
different zone or region,
in case of failure.
We have no cross-zone
communication,
except for database replication.
So NGINX is the back-end service
for the global load balancer.
So that way, if a zone
goes down or even,
for that matter, if you
want to test something
on a specific zone, we can
just shut down that NGINX.
And LB will automatically
detect that the--
the LB will automatically detect
that the health check fails
on that zone, and then
it draws the traffic
to the other regions.
Yeah, so the fourth one
is kind of interesting--
adjusting the
load-balancing mode
to send traffic
to all the zones.
Well, so with our
pattern of on-prem--
it sends on-prem to the
Google Cloud, right--
our on-prem infrastructure
is hosted in central region.
So the request which
comes from on-prem
hits only the central zones.
Now, what happens in
that case is that--
the infrastructure
which is [INAUDIBLE]
on the other region, the east
region, is underutilized.
And when we get some
amount of high traffic,
we auto-scale on
the central zones.
But the east ones, they
never get utilized, right?
So this is one of the things
which we did recently,
is that we adjusted the
load-balancing mode, which
allowed us to send
traffic to all the zones,
even if the request is coming
from a specific region.
So that allowed us to be
more effective in our cost
and not auto-scale unless
it's absolutely necessary.
Yeah, and for
internal traffic, we
use a service discovery tool.
It's a [INAUDIBLE] console,
which is, again, zone-isolated.
So when we have a
service-to-service call
in a specific zone, the
service discovery tool
allows us to only get the IPs
for that zone, which does not
allow us to do a cross-zone or
a cross-regional call, yeah.
That's pretty much it.
LUKE STONE: So
what are the steps
that you take when you're
setting up a new microservice?
KUMAR: So are you asking about
what do we use to deploy, or--
LUKE STONE: Yeah,
what components
do you need to change
to add a microservice?
KUMAR: So when we
add a microservice,
the only thing which we do
is we deploy a microservice.
So we have a CI/CD
[? pipeline- ?] model,
which deploys the microservice.
And then we add the
context to NGINX.
And if there is any associated
back-end or data deal,
then we deploy that.
So we go backwards.
We first deploy the
back-end component,
then we deploy the
microservice, and then
update NGINX to send
traffic to it, yeah.
LUKE STONE: Nice.
And how do you roll out a new
version of a microservice?
KUMAR: Yeah, so we
use managed instance
groups for all our deployments.
So if you want to roll
out a new deployment,
well, basically
a new version, we
deploy a new make, a new
managed instance group,
which basically has
the same service name.
And then the traffic
is sent to both the old
and the new instances
for a period of time,
before we shut down the
old instance groups.
And then we have traffic
only on the new version.
LUKE STONE: Nice.
So are you pretty
happy with this setup?
Is there anything major
that you would change?
KUMAR: Yeah, well, it
works for us, for now.
But there are some things,
actually, we are looking at.
One of the things--
it works for status
applications where
all instances are similar.
But there are some
scenarios where
we don't want to send
traffic right away,
after the instance comes up.
We want to do some kind of--
we do health checks.
But more than health
checks, you might
have to do some validation or--
specifically for
database tiers, right, we
might want to do some
autowarming or some caching,
and make sure that there's
one cache before we send data
to it, right?
So for that, we are working
on a different model
where we deploy the
instance, do health checks,
and then send
traffic to it, which
is a different pattern than what
we are using right now, yeah.
JAY: So more robust
health checks,
more than is really capable
with HTTP load balancer
or even Console.
I mean, a significant
validation of the service,
that the data is
valid that we just fed
into it, that kind of thing.
LUKE STONE: Makes sense.
CUONG: So actually, when we
deploy, it deploy to each zone.
So an engineer
deploys to one zone.
And then if it's good, it's
brought to the next zone.
And if it's bad, then
we just roll it out.
So we can do each
zone at a time,
so we don't have to
do it at one shot.
LUKE STONE: So do you have your
dev teams do the roll-outs,
or is the SRE team always
doing the roll-outs?
CUONG: For production
today, it's mostly SRE.
But for a long lifecycle,
it's automatic.
We have a CI/CD that
automatically deploy it
once the code are committed
in a long lifecycle.
But in the future, I think
we want, potentially,
that development can even do the
deployment themselves as well.
LUKE STONE: Nice,
that's awesome.
That's one of the SRE
principles that we
like to remind
people of, is always
have the dev team do some
portion of the production work,
so they know about it.
They have their
hands on production.
They're aware of
it, and then they
can sympathize a little bit.
So, Jay, what's your
experience with setting up
SRE in Home Depot
and working with CRE?
JAY: The CRE engagement
that we had was really,
really eye opening.
We did a lot of--
there's a lot of
literature about SRE--
probably, most notably, the
book that Google SREs wrote.
But sometimes it's hard
to take those practices
and really, really
apply them and then,
even when you do successfully
apply them, really making sure
that it's achieving
what you expected it to,
that you haven't left gaps.
And not just with that, but
with our entire architecture--
we've spent a little
bit of time doing this.
But there's obviously
a lot of things
that you can think
you got right.
But when you actually encounter
an unexpected failure mode
or there's a lot of things
that you can find that, hey,
we thought we had it
right, but we didn't.
And the CRE engagement was
extremely valuable for us,
I think.
Just to kind of recap--
I know, probably, some of you
heard William and Luke's talk
earlier.
But Google CRE came and worked
with our teams for at least--
was it two or three months,
something like that?
LUKE STONE: It was
August until Black Friday
at the end of November.
JAY: Yeah, it was an
extended engagement.
And basically, CRE sat down
over multiple meetings,
really poring over multiple
aspects of our architecture,
how we did deployments,
how we were monitoring
things, how we did
service discovery, how
we were load balancing--
really, really dug deep.
I was really, actually,
shocked with how much
they were interested in not just
how we were using Google Cloud
components, but actually how--
the open-source
software we were using.
And were we using
it effectively,
and what risks did
those introduce,
and did we have proper
mitigations for those?
Really dug deep into all aspects
of our platform architecture
and provided extremely
valuable feedback.
It was a little bit
terrifying, I think.
Just part of the
team of guys that
made a lot of the
decisions about
how we were going to do this
stuff, and kind of exposing all
of that, and really
having to talk
about it with experts that--
you kind of feel, maybe,
at a different class
and used to a different scale.
But it was extremely,
extremely valuable.
They really showed us
some things that were--
some problems that we hadn't
anticipated, hadn't thought
about, but really, more
than that, really showing us
how SREs should engage with
providing that model for how
our SRE team should be engaging
with our development teams,
with our app teams that
are building these things,
and what kind of reviews we
should be doing with them,
I thought was probably the
most valuable out of it.
The technical
issues that we found
and the gaps that we had--
obviously, that helped a lot.
But really showing us
how to do SRE, I think,
was the biggest thing.
LUKE STONE: Yeah,
that whole deep dive
was led by our tech lead Matt
Brown, who's right over there.
And we had to learn a
whole bunch of stuff
too, because we don't
run Cassandra at Google.
JAY: Right, Console, yeah.
LUKE STONE: So we had
to kind of figure out
how to analyze these things
from first principles.
And Matt came up
with a good rule
of thumb, which is
that we would look
at the API between your
system and Cloud API, right?
Just like the API is--
well, sometimes it's
actually an API call.
But sometimes the API
is basically POSIX
if you're running
on a VM or whatever.
And then Matt's rule of thumb
is then, look one layer deeper
in levels of abstraction.
So we kind of
understand, oh, yeah.
Cassandra says that
it runs on a VM,
but actually what's it doing?
What's its purpose?
How much data is it going
to push, over what lengths?
Is it going to be quiet, and
then all of a sudden bursty?
Or what's going
to happen with it?
JAY: Right, yeah, like I
said, it was really great.
And the depth with which
you guys went into,
not just the Google things, not
just how we were doing instance
groups or how we were
using the load balancer,
but really that extra
step that I think
provided the biggest value.
I think William
mentioned it earlier.
I've been involved,
William's been involved
with a number of
consulting engagements
and with other vendors,
and this was by far the--
at least in my opinion,
was the most useful one.
LUKE STONE: Yeah,
before we started,
we were kind of trying to
tell William what to expect.
And we said, you know,
William, this is not
the white-glove treatment.
This is more like the
rubber-glove treatment.
JAY: Yeah, it was.
LUKE STONE: And it was cool.
JAY: And that's why I
said it was a little bit
terrifying at first, right?
Man, we're really going to
put all our cards on the table
here and have people
really pick this apart.
But it's better--
obviously, it's
better in advance than doing
this with your CIO or something
after a major, major
incident, right?
LUKE STONE: Yeah,
that's kind of our--
that's kind of the idea is that,
well, you have postmortems,
and you will continually
improve if you use postmortems
correctly.
You might as well start
off at a pretty good level
to begin with.
JAY: Right, absolutely.
LUKE STONE: So how has it
affected your engineering
culture to have an SRE
team, because you're pretty
new within your organization?
JAY: It's obviously-- I think
we kind of alluded to it.
It's still a little
bit incremental.
We're still trying to get better
and to do things a little bit
better every day, right?
And I think that that's
the biggest thing is just--
we've kind of had--
it's the way, at least
in my experience--
I've been with Home
Depot for a while.
And really being
able to establish
SLAs and say, what
error rate is OK, right?
Is this a problem?
Historically, we've kind of--
well, it could be better.
So let's keep it
better, and really
having that establishment
of, well, OK.
What's really the number
that we care about
and the numbers that we need
to achieve for our business?
And then, as long as
we're under that, then
we don't have to
worry as much, right?
That's a big change
for us, I think.
I think that's really
adjusted our mentality,
and it's kind of helped to
make the operations SRE role
a little bit more sustainable,
which is important,
because we've--
I've been doing this for a
while, and a lot of times,
it's been extremely,
extremely taxing, right?
I'm sure we could share
war stories for a while.
But it's been a
lot of always on,
a lot of burning the
candle at both ends,
trying to get things done, keep
things up, get things ready.
And for anybody, it
takes a toll, right?
You can only do
that for so long.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, have you
noticed any significant changes
in your development velocity?
JAY: Probably-- I haven't
really tracked it that closely.
I think that we probably have.
I think that especially
for our application team,
we've provided kind
of the paved road of,
hey, here's a
pattern that works.
Here's a model that works.
And if you follow
that path, things
will generally be
pretty good for you,
and you won't have
a lot of trouble.
And certainly, once
an app is launched,
I think that we have--
and it's not just SRE.
I think that it's a number of
principles of solid testing.
And just our overall
software engineering practice
is also kind of changing
at the same time
that we're implementing SRE.
And that's definitely
provided us
a lift in how quick we
can get things rolled out.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, I notice you
guys centralized your CI/CD.
And you have an
engineer, Christo,
who's making a really
great CI/CD platform
that all the dev teams can use.
And he got out ahead
of the problem,
and so now everybody just
uses it, and it's solved.
JAY: Yeah, and as
long as you use that,
and you follow a few not
overly constraining practices,
if you follow that,
then it's pretty
easy to get your app
running and to deploy
new versions of your app.
And it just kind
of works, right.
LUKE STONE: So one thing
William was mentioning
was how your strategy is--
you have this monolithic
legacy architecture
that's sitting on-prem in
your data center, right?
And your strategy
has been to bite off
one microservice at a time and
implement that microservice
in the cloud, right?
And then you just imagine,
like you take a class
and move it to the cloud,
and it's in the server.
And then you just call
to it over an RPC.
How does that work for you?
JAY: It's been a
journey that we've
been on for a while, of breaking
components out of our monolith
and deploying those
separately, even
in our on-prem environment.
We've been on this journey
for a little while.
Definitely, moving it
out of your data center
adds some additional
challenges, right?
What was maybe a few
milliseconds of latency
now becomes--
I think we've got roughly, what,
40, 50 milliseconds of latency
to our services in Google.
So that's been a little
bit of a challenge of,
how do you manage that?
And so you have
to carefully plan
how you're going to
move components and move
their dependencies.
And do you move a
back-end API to Google
before you move the
front end, and then
have your customers
kind of ping-ponging
between the components?
Sometimes the unfortunate
answer is, sometimes
we have to do that, right?
We've got to be able to get
the service out, running.
We've got to make sure that
it's actually functional.
Well, then the
only way to do that
is to put customer
traffic on it.
And if we have to eat a little
bit of latency in there,
then we make that as a kind of
an informed decision and say,
hey, this is going to
be the state we're going
to be in for a little while.
And other times it's, well, we
don't really have to do that.
We can move the
front end as well,
and maybe move both
components at the same time.
So it's kind of a
case-by-case thing
of how we're going to do that.
But yeah, in general,
it's worked pretty well.
I think it's a good model.
LUKE STONE: How
do you decide how
big to make the microservice?
JAY: That's a great question.
Definitely, I think
we've got some
that we feel like
maybe are maybe
smaller than they should be.
And I think we've
definitely got some that are
larger than we would like them.
But that's an evolution, right?
I think, especially
once we migrate and--
it becomes relatively easy.
On-prem, we had--
creating a new cluster,
deploying a new application,
there was a lot of process
and a lot of things you had
to go through to do that.
It just didn't-- there's not an
API you can call and get a new
set of servers racked, right?
You had to-- sometimes
it was procurement.
Sometimes it was
multiple teams that you
would have to go through
to get them cabled,
and get firewall policies,
and all that stuff.
So I think at least my
opinion is that once
you've migrated to the
app, even if it's bigger
than you wanted it to be
and wasn't perfectly sized
microservice, textbook, whatever
that is, that you can always
come back and break it down
later, and divide it up
as it makes sense.
And it's much easier
then, because now you've
got a system that's basically
designed to change and adapt
much more fluidly.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, so if you've
got 70, 80 microservices,
you're going to have a lot of
logging and monitoring streams.
How do you keep this
stuff all straight?
JAY: Well, I don't know
that we've hit it out
of the park on all of it.
We're definitely using
Stackdriver for our core
metrics, and we've had to get
creative with some things,
right?
I'm also using Stackdriver,
Google logging, and Fluentd
Agent to push all of our
log streams into logging API
and ultimately into BigQuery.
We've had a few
challenges with having
to get our data structured well
enough that we could actually
utilize it effectively and be
able to run queries against it.
And then we've built tools,
like we were mentioning
with the VALET dashboard
that we had there that
shows the aggregate metrics.
We've built tools to make it
easier for big queries to get
run-- basically, an API that
you can call to run the query
for gathering an hour,
or two hours, or a day,
or whatever time frame you
need of the metrics for that
application, and then being able
to expose it in multiple ways--
a chat bot or being
able to push it
into a long-term kind
of aggregated metrics,
like the VALET dashboard.
And then we've done some things
even with the Stackdriver
collectd that--
we're still working towards
actually having our application
submit the metrics.
So we got creative with some
of the things that were capable
there and did use
[INAUDIBLE] plugin
to scrape our real-time
metrics that we wanted out
of the log files as well.
Obviously, we're working on
trying to improve that and make
it more scalable.
It's got a little-- there's
a few problems with it.
It's a little more hands-on
than we want it to be.
So we're trying to come up
with new and creative ways
to gather that without having to
have such a dependence on logs.
LUKE STONE: Yeah, I liked--
a couple things you did
seemed pretty smart.
There were some
Slack bots that you
built that would put a bunch
of stuff into a Slack channel.
So people could just kind
of watch the Slack channel,
and you'd have a pretty good
idea of what's going on.
That was pretty cool.
JAY: Yeah, and we've used
that fairly effectively.
And it's basically the same--
the site bot's relatively dumb.
It just presents the data.
But the actual application that
we wrote that we call our TPS
reports, which is--
basically, it just
goes out, and you
can feed it an application
name and a time frame
and it will go query
BigQuery for that
and provide back the data.
And I think even, in
some cases, it actually
notes that compared
to the SLO of what
the application's expecting.
So you can clearly see if,
even on a one-hour time frame
or a custom time frame,
whatever you want--
is this app healthy?
Is it OK?
And anybody can query that.
It's available to the
whole company, right?
Anybody can join our Slack
and run those queries.
LUKE STONE: Yeah,
the other thing
I thought was pretty
cool that came up
when we were doing a
wheel of misfortune
one time was you had your
deployment script log
everything that it
was doing to BigQuery.
So you could go into
BigQuery and be like, OK,
when did this deployment start?
Who did it?
What's going on here?
That was pretty cool.
JAY: Yeah, that's a
more direct integration.
So we use Fluentd on our
nodes to collect the logs--
not just our application
logs, but other--
Syslog and other general
logs of interest.
But our deployment tool actually
logs directly to the API,
and it actually is
very clear about what--
you can see exactly what the
deployment tool is doing,
even if you're not sitting
in front of the screen,
running the deployments
yourself, right?
It's fairly real-time to
see what's going on there.
LUKE STONE: That's cool.
So what technologies are
you looking forward to?
What are you going to adopt
as soon as it becomes GA?
JAY: I don't know.
We kind of worked around the
lack of internal load balancers
early on, and so that's
one thing that we've
been considering.
Should we revisit that?
Should we look back at--
since the internal load
balancers are GA now,
should we evaluate
using that instead
of our home-grown
solution that we use?
Other than that, I don't know.
Spanner looks really cool, but I
could probably geek out all day
and say--
and as a matter of fact,
through our engagement,
we've had so many Google
product teams wanting--
like, hey, we've got
this thing that's coming.
Would you be
interested in doing--
testing with it, alpha testing?
We'd like your feedback.
And it was kind of like,
you could definitely get
overwhelmed with
the all-you-can-eat,
because then once they ask you
to do that, and you say, oh,
yeah.
That sounds cool.
And then they want feedback
on, how did it work,
and what did you
think, and all that.
So it's kind of a--
you can definitely
overload on that, so.
KUMAR: XBN.
JAY: Yeah, so XBN is something
that we've been interested in.
So right now, we've kind
of got some growing pains.
Within our project, we're
kind of consolidated
with most of our applications,
all in one project.
And we've run into some problems
there with API quota limits.
And some of those are soft
limits that we can get raised,
and some of them are
like, no, we really
can't change that for you.
So we're considering
XBN and using
XBN to allow us to
spread our services out
over multiple projects to
still communicate internally
and fairly openly and
freely across that,
but to be able to decompose
down to multiple projects.
LUKE STONE: Nice.
So I was wondering if we
had any questions-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you
taking questions?
LUKE STONE: Yes, please do.
I think this is a great time.
We got about 12 minutes left.
AUDIENCE: So during the keynote
this morning, your Home Depot
guy mentioned that you
have moved part of the data
warehouse into
BigQuery, and then he
avoided an answer about the
problems that you were having.
JAY: And if our SVP avoided
it, I probably will to.
We use BigQuery,
in our operation,
mainly for log analysis.
And we've got a few other
use cases we're using.
We have another team that's
doing data warehousing,
and they can probably
answer your questions
much better than I can.
I don't--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LUKE STONE: Bring back
the mic so they can talk.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
LUKE STONE: Have
you been helped?
AUDIENCE: So he
avoided the answer
in order to say
why not succeeded,
and then he was arguing
about looking for talent
and working off interesting
problems and so forth.
LUKE STONE: This is Shashi.
He's also an SRE at Home Depot.
SHASHI: We have two teams.
One of them is being our
ADW team, warehouse team.
They started using BigQuery.
I don't recall them mentioning
any issues with that.
We are the e-commerce
team, make sense?
AUDIENCE: Especially when
it comes down to, let's say,
unpredicted queries,
so these joint issues
and these kind of things--
there is not really an
issue, performance-wise?
So performance is good, from
your point of view, yeah?
SHASHI: So from other
[INAUDIBLE] sorry.
From the e-commerce
point of view,
you're asking about
the select queries,
whether when you are doing
some views on top of it,
how is the performance of the
BigQuery and all that stuff.
For our reporting, e-commerce
reporting purposes, logging
reporting purposes, whatever
the queries we are running,
we do not see any
issues, as of now.
KUMAR: Yeah, so
the one area where
we use BigQuery is that
all our transactional data
gets fed into BigQuery through
an incoming job or a process.
And the production
operations, then they
will go to our transactional
data store to query something.
They go to BigQuery, and it's
working out pretty well for us.
AUDIENCE: OK, so before
we had the SRE book,
we had the testing
book from Google.
So I'm wondering how the SREs
interact with the software
engineer testing teams.
LUKE STONE: Shashi again.
SHASHI: So we do have a
performance engineering team.
They do all the stress
tests on our microservices.
And now what we have,
transitioning that
into SRE teams--
so now SRE teams
and dev teams, we
are empowering them to do
their own stress tests,
so that when they
deploy their service--
before deploying their service,
they can do the stress test,
load test, check their SLOs,
volumetrics, and all that kind
of good stuff.
And then once they
get a clean signal,
it's part of the CI/CD flow.
That's what we are
planning, and then it
will get a green signal.
And then they can
go to production.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you have
a large, monolithic, on-prem
system still running.
I wonder what criteria you
use to peel off functionality
from the monolithic system
to build these microservices.
JAY: So I'll take
this opportunity
to plug my boss's talk tomorrow.
So he's actually going to talk
pretty extensively about this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAY: But I think
the short answer is,
based on what's easiest, right?
That's where we kind of
started with this was,
what were the easier
things to separate?
And additionally, what things,
what components of the site
did we want to be able to
update more rapidly than what
it was really feasible to do
with the monolithic components?
So those were probably the
two kind of core things.
AUDIENCE: How much of your
time you spend on automation
versus operations?
JAY: I don't know.
I don't know if I have a
good, hard metric on that.
I would say that, probably,
too much time on operations
right now--
I think we really want to
get more to automating.
It's, I would say, probably
50-50 at worst case right now.
I think that a lot
of our time is--
KUMAR: Yeah, it
probably started off
at 20-80, maybe 20
automation and 80 operations.
But I think we are, right
now, close to 50-50.
I think we are getting better.
There is more
automated deployments
and automated processes
which we have in place.
So one of the things which
we still need to work on
is automated tests.
We are not 100% on
that, so we still
have to do a lot of
manual validation.
So that's something which
we're working on, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, how do you
divide application support
across the teams?
So how is the
application architecture
itself divided among the
teams, in terms of support?
KUMAR: Architecture
or just support?
AUDIENCE: The product itself--
how are the
applications divided?
SHASHI: I'm sorry.
Can you repeat one more, just
the last sentence, last one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
the product is divided
into multiple components.
SHASHI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And SRE
teams are handling,
managing, maintaining, and
supporting these components.
My question is,
how many components
or how much of this product
is divided between teams?
So how many application
does each team support?
SHASHI: Oh, you mean each
SRE, how many applications
it supports?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SHASHI: There is no
hard-and-fast rule for it.
It depends on the
velocity of the changes.
It depends on the critical
nature of the application,
so we have primary SREs, that's
what you're talking about,
so primary SREs, secondary SREs.
And then the one SRE would
be on call, that kind
of operational issues.
But there is no
hard-and-fast rule for that--
one application should
have 10 SREs or five SREs.
There is no rule for that.
It depends on the application.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JAY: We do generally
bucket our applications up
between what we call
the browse components
of our site versus the My
Cart and Checkout components.
And so we have separate
SRE teams that--
they work closely in
conjunction with each other.
But applications are generally
bucketed towards that.
Obviously, we've got a lot that
kind of fit the middle ground.
They're not perfectly
one nor the other.
They're maybe
shared or whatever,
but, generally, we assign
them to one team or the other.
And then within
each of those teams,
there's multiple
SREs that divide
those up with expertise
on each one, deeper
knowledge on each one.